العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا
المطار الذي كان مسرحا لعمليات عسكريه
خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو الان بهذه الوضعيه
وبهذه الشاكله بعد اشتداد العمليات
العسكريه والحربيه والاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه المنطقه الان
هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من المطار هو حيوي
يتعلق بهبوط بقيام الطائرات التدريبات
كانت في هذا المكان الان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تنتشر في محيط وفي ارجاء هذا
المكان تتمركز في مختلف الاتجاهات في
الاتجاه الشمالي في الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي
الاتجاه الغربي وفي الاتجاه الشرقي حسب
افادات خاصه للعربيه والحدث بان الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
تفرز بالكامل على كل مداخل ومخارج هذا
المطار والقاعده العملاتيه الجويه هنا في
مدينه مروي شمال السودان يوم الامس دارت
اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره تعاملت الطيران او تعامل الطيران
الجيش السوداني مع من خرج من هذه القاعده
وكبدهم خسائر فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر
عسكريه الان هذا المطار بكلياته بكامله في
يد الجيش السوداني ويدى القوات المسلحه من
داخل مطار مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه نزار البغداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات